someone was like I missed the the Joe
exotic stimulus check part of quarantine
yeah this is dark when I was a little
boy never were you a little boy okay
you're right but I play with
imaginations all the time to this day I
do still too and every week I was
something else one day I was a pirate
the next day I was a Marvel superhero
do you all remember that and every day
the couch was something else - she was
the princess the next she was the
mermaid debby WF I always thought I was
like a wrestler cuz I was like big in my
time yeah where it was big in hard times
in it
oh yeah oh wait did you have siblings
yeah older brother he just booked me oh
okay cause I was gonna say like I used
to do I should see what I was only child
so it's like I was kind of oh you just
play with your friends don't I mean even
like when I was in preschool and I had
friends I remember specifically the
teacher was like - my dad your son has
such a vivid imagination cuz I guess I
was like pretending I was Inspector
Gadget oh [ __ ] I was doing this and I
was like be taking this was my magnet
eat you told me you were being you doing
this and I and I was like a spy on girls
yeah friends like which are just
neighbors though cuz when I whenever
there was a kid like I was just a flirt
dude I was over there hey you want to
play I'm gonna see you doing yeah but
then [ __ ] Mario next door stole my
ninja turtles and I thought and I was
like mad at him for a long time and then
I accused him of stealing my little
there was like a lizard that used to
kick it with in his Turtles he was on a
skateboard - and I thought he stole that
one of mine but I actually lost it in a
bush so I felt bad for you boys in my
bushes and I blamed other kid
look under the bushes let me take all
these toys I mean you feel like [ __ ]
yeah you make it mistake
well these boys their imagination is so
strong they let a black widow bite them
in hopes of turning into spider oh no no
no I though I used to think that would
be possible too but I was like that's
too painful give away the spider web now
it's time we can all connect so there's
three young Bolivian brothers and they
were hospitalized after getting back
white black widow spiders bit black boy
oh yeah they wanted to beat spider-man
but get this man they got it wrong
because you have to be white first have
you three Latinos look you trying to get
bit by spiders yeah what would the three
Latinos turn into just like venom just
just sick I just say yeah so the thing
is they're 12 10 and eight mmm
I think at this age you should know by
now well the 12 year old for you maybe
not by eight year old but also I don't
know how educated they are because
they're out hurting goats in diantha
diantha and they're just they were
herding goats and then they decided what
a good idea they found a spider Wow
spider-man if they're just goat herders
fool they have no nothing to swing that
animation of us my rather losing the the
farm nah like Hillary just swings I just
[ __ ] smack the floor that's funny so
they thought that they'll get superhero
powers and they thought that don't just
stick with it and get a little bit sick
until they actually become spider-man
yeah all three got bit well yeah they
already got bit their mom found him
crying and they they rushed him to a
health center and then they transferred
to him nearby hospital [ __ ] yeah it's
the most dangerous spider in the world
no no no you can get bill you'll be fine
just gotta go like cuz I just get really
sick yes people that
and they literally get bit and just like
immediately like you start getting like
like this pain like if I they were they
were dealing with fevers tremors and
muscle pains yeah well you do get in the
brown recluse spiders have you seen
those like your skin just starts to
[ __ ] peel off and like the giant
holes in your body is that the most
deadliest spider I don't know I don't
know what the most deadliest spider Oh
in terms of venom I heard they're the
most I've heard that they're things
aren't long enough to pierce skins like
beyond their end plus like your legs are
so [ __ ] like they don't really ever
but I heard they're like trying to bite
you that too longs to where they just
can't
so what blew my mind is that the venom
of a black widow is 15 times stronger
than a rattlesnake
yeah I didn't know that either checked
enough rattlesnakes can kill you I think
just because how much they inject into
someone so like the amount the volume
drop her drop it do you have any more
but rousing way more volume before they
were kid though probably could have been
deadly okay so that means like you know
sometimes you see a ton of them in the
in the garage or backyard if you got bit
by a ton you can probably die that yeah
for sure oh [ __ ] dude I never got bit by
a black widow but as soon as I see them
I am Peter gonna hate me I think that
the spray with the lighter yeah worried
you got a torch um I just suck him up
with the vacuum but what if it crawls
back out no that one yeah I guess you're
right they have an orgy in there like mm
come out my god damn have you crazy what
would you guys do if your kids did this
something this stupid cuz I feel like
Alma what's gonna happen don't weigh the
kid so it all gets true I think if
you're Asian intended you probably all
at home you should intended yeah cuz
Tyco was running on the the he was
running and then it was a wet spot on
the cement so he slipped and fell and
then it
they say starts crying right and I go I
told you not to run and then Jill was
like how come you idiot aegeon part
where like you know you're like [ __ ] I
[ __ ] told you not to look laugh yeah
that comes out first yeah it's so hard
being a parent cuz like I have two sides
to me where like I wanted to be more
nurturing but then some parts of me I'm
like the [ __ ] up and get up and like and
just like that's [ __ ] life now you're
gonna fall ten thousand more times and
get used to it you know years old
[ __ ] change your [ __ ] diaper idiot
yeah my dad what are you [ __ ]
yourself dude I got physically hurt he
would it was okay to cry it's just you
can't cry from just like being
emotionally hurt so like if I got
physically hurt and I like ran into a
table or something he'd be like who did
it the table damned
doing that for future babies that's like
all I middle east soon as they hit the
thing that hurt that it's not the floor
and stuff Laura but then it teaches her
and long one to blame other things be
honor that's good cuz you hide your
emotions for everything yeah when I
would cry over like emotional things
like if I just had feelings like I get
caught of my feelings a lot like if I'm
in the club you know my feelings and
he'd be like why are you crying are you
hurt and I'd be like no and he's like
well you could only cry if you're hurt
no but it feels like I'm hurt cuz he
can't find what to slap ya you can't
slap your heart yeah
[Laughter]
geez something cry for him moms do have
a different effect of like every time I
fell my dad would just pick me up dust
me off and he's like all right cool
yeah hate over my dad yeah and I'm like
what tell mama calm you see there's
something missing a [ __ ] dude and every
time my mom I'll be like oh [ __ ] there's
like a thing that she does she's this
magical oh yeah [ __ ] if I ever had a cut
or a little Lulu alley or whatever yeah
my mom would do a thing where she would
like like it was my niece you would go
okay whoa yeah and it was better
it's like [ __ ] magic nude I have I
still have scars till this day on my
knee
dude I fell gashes shake up [ __ ] up
right and my dad was like what did you
do he picked me up and he's like you
could walk I was walking like [ __ ] up
wait she ran over she checked this goes
we might have to go to the hospital it's
too expensive
and if she goes huh you know it like
walk you with a [ __ ] peg leg and I'm
like it's better I'm like riding a bike
and I crash yeah my dad your son fell at
least the kids were ambitious they're
like hey do we want to be go herders the
rest of our life or do we want to be
spider-man and I feel like that was the
pitch and it's like yeah you're right or
do we want to be Spider Men spider like
it's a joy you go bypass my bypass okay
all did at the same time was it had one
spider they passed around
I found three that's like it's done when
you have one and you see the brother
like crying in pain how did I get out I
don't want to be spying they were gonna
stick it out like they were their idea
was like let's stick out if you watch
the movie he goes ah that's it
you watch Tobey Maguire he goes home and
he's like feels like [ __ ] yeah kids the
wrong ABS look it's all buffa [ __ ] yeah
he wakes up the next morning is no work
no more yeah veins like start popping
out too and then he has a little [ __ ]
yeah yeah so it says they prodded the
spider with the stick until it bit each
of them oh my intern it was the same
spider they're torturing the spider all
I can think of when you say that is an
animal crossing when Miss Korea chiller
comes and it's like and you could walk
away but it's like you want to catch it
cuz it's expensive
and so it goes back down and you get
closer to that yeah and then you end it
goes back down
and then you get close enough we could
catch it with a net I wanted a head
trance
I watched I watched if play all the time
though I loved it it's all like
collecting things you can build DIYs for
home decor and then like like plants and
stuff and then you'd like build a museum
out it's awesome I want I wanted a pet
tarantula littles big-ass ones yeah in
junior high but they're free yeah but my
parents didn't let me because my mom was
scared of it yeah I wanted dude I had a
lot of pets did you I had a turtle I had
two hamsters I had a rat I had a dog I
had a could I say turtle I had a frog
and a salamander damn yeah an Ace
Ventura v so yeah and then my friend
caught a sparrow and I kept that
[ __ ]
you got that spirit you know what he
used to do so sparrows used to go into
these signs and he would go around the
neighborhood and just shake it and as
the sparrows fly out he has a grocery
bag and you would catch the and he came
it he came over and it was a baby so I
didn't know how to fly yet and it was my
first like real heartbreak death
cuz my dog didn't die yet so you know
had that guy I called a baby lizard and
I put it in a Tupperware out like a and
they would eat it leaves and gave it
sticks and stuff and I had it outside
and then we went to the pool and it
ended up baking to death in the Sun I
came home I was so [ __ ] horrified and
I felt so guilty and so bad I never
caught lizards again and he was like you
open the thing and he's like you know
you can save on insurance if you
[Laughter]
[Music]
you